growing up in northern Wisconsin
I've naturally developed a connection to
the Mississippi River when I was little
my sister and I would have contests to
see who could spell em is s is s IPP I
the fastest when I was in elementary
school I got to learn about the early
explorers and their expeditions
Marquette and Joliet and how they use
the Great Lakes and the Mississippi
River and it's tributaries to discover
the Midwest and to map a trade route to
the Gulf of Mexico in graduate school I
was fortunate to have the Mississippi
River outside my research laboratory
window at the University of Minnesota
during that five-year period I got to
know the Mississippi River I got to know
is temperamental nature on where it
would flood its banks at one moment and
then shortly thereafter you would see
it's dry shorelines today as a physical
organic chemist I'm committed to use my
training to help protect rivers like the
Mississippi from excessive salt that can
come from human activity because you
know salt is something that can
contaminate fresh water rivers and
freshwater rivers they have only salt
levels of Oh point zero five percent and
at this level it's safe to drink but the
majority of the water on our planet is
housed in our oceans and ocean water has
a salinity level of more than three
percent and if you drink that you'd be
sick very quick so if we are to compare
the relative volume of ocean water to
that of the river water that's on our
planet and let's say we're able to put
the ocean water into an Olympic sized
swimming pool then our planet's River
water would fit in a one gallon jug so
you can see it's a precious resource
but do we treat it like a precious or
source or rather do we treat it like
that old rug that you put in your front
doorway and wipe your feet off on it
treating rivers like that old rug has
severe consequences let's take a look
let's see what just one teaspoon of salt
can do if we add one teaspoon of salt to
this Olympic sized swimming pool of
ocean water the ocean water stays ocean
water but if we add that same one
teaspoon of salt to this one gallon jug
of fresh river water suddenly it becomes
too salty to drink so the point here is
because rivers the volume is so small
compared to the oceans it is especially
vulnerable to human activity and we need
to take care to protect them so recently
I surveyed the literature to look at the
river health around the world and I
fully expected to see ailing River
health in regions of water scarcity and
heavy industrial development and I saw
that in northern China and in India what
I was surprised when I read a 2018
article where there is 232 River
sampling sites sampled across the United
States and of those sites 37 percent had
increasing salinity levels what was more
surprising is that the ones with the
highest increases were found on the east
part of the United States and not the
arid Southwest the authors of this paper
postulate that this could be due to
using salt 2d ice roads potentially
another source of the salt could come
from salty industrial waste waters so as
you see human activities can convert our
freshwater rivers into water that's more
like our oceans so we need to act and do
something before it's too late and I
have a proposal we can take a three step
river defense mechanism and if
industrial water users practice this
defense mechanism we can
put our rivers in a much safer position
this involves number one extracting less
water from our rivers by implementing
water recycle and reuse operations
number two we need to take the salt out
of these salty industrial waste waters
and recover it and reuse it for other
purposes and number three we need to
convert salt consumers who currently
source their salt from mines into salt
consumers at source their salt from
recycled salt sources this three part
defense mechanism is already in play
this is what northern China and India
are implementing to help to rehabilitate
the rivers but the proposal here is to
use this defense mechanism to protect
our rivers so we don't need to
rehabilitate them and the good news is
we have technology that can do this it's
with membranes membranes that can
separate salt and water membranes have
been around for a number of years and
they're based on polymeric materials
that separate based on size or they can
separate based on charge the membranes
that are used to separate salt and water
typically separate based on charge and
these membranes are negatively charged
and helped to repel the negatively
charged chloride ions that are in that
dissolved salt so as I said these
membranes have been around for a number
of years and currently they are
purifying 25 million gallons of water
every minute even more than that
actually but they can do more these
membranes are based under the principle
of reverse osmosis now osmosis is this
natural process that happens in our
bodies you know how our cells work and
osmosis is where you have two chambers
that separate two levels of salt
concentration one with low salt
concentration and one with high salt
concentration and the separating the two
chambers is the semipermeable membrane
and under the natural I suppose
this process what happens is the water
naturally transports across that
membrane from the area of low salt
concentration to the area of high salt
concentration until an equilibrium is
met
now reverse osmosis it's the reverse of
this natural process and in order to
achieve this reversal what we do is we
apply a pressure to the high
concentration side and in doing so we
drive the water the opposite direction
and so the high concentration side
becomes more salty more concentrated and
the low concentration side becomes your
purified water so using reverse osmosis
we can take an industrial wastewater and
convert up to 95% of it into pure water
leaving only 5% as this concentrated
salty mixture now this five percent
concentrated salty mixture is not waste
so scientists have also developed
membranes that that are modified to
allow some salt to pass through and not
others using these membranes which are
commonly referred to as nano filtration
membranes now this five percent
concentrated salty solution can be
converted into a purified salt solution
so in total using reverse osmosis and
nano filtration membranes we can convert
industrial wastewater into a resource of
both water and salt and in doing so
achieve pillars one and two of this
river defense mechanism now I've
introduced this to a number of
industrial water users and the common
response is yeah but who's gonna use my
salt so that's why pillar number three
is so important we need to transform
folks that are using mined salt into
consumers of recycled salt so who are
these salt consumers well in 2018 in the
United States
I learned that 43% of the salt consumed
in the US was used for road salt
de-icing purposes thirty-nine percent
was used by the chemical industry
so let's take a look at these two
applications so I was shocked I in
2018-2019 winter season 1 million tons
of salt was applied to the roads in the
state of Pennsylvania 1 million tons of
salt is enough to fill two thirds of an
Empire State Building
that's 1 million tons of salt mined from
the earth applied to our roads and that
it washes off into the environment and
into our rivers so the proposal here is
that we could at least source that salt
from a salty industrial wastewater and
prevent that from going into our rivers
and rather use that to apply to our
roads so at least when the melt happens
in the springtime and you have this high
salinity runoff the rivers are at least
in a better position to defend
themselves against that now as a chemist
the the opportunity though that I I'm
more psyched about is the concept of
introducing circular salt into the
chemical industry and the chloral alkali
industry is perfect chlor-alkali
industry is the source of of epoxies
it's the source of urethanes and
solvents and a lot of useful products
that we use in our everyday lives and it
uses sodium chloride salt as its key
feedstock so the idea here is well first
of all let's look at linear economy so
in the linear economy they're sourcing
that salt from a mine it goes through
this chlor-alkali process made into a
basic chemical which then can get
converted into another new product or a
more functional product but during that
conversion process oftentimes salts is
regenerated as the byproduct and it ends
up in the industrial wastewater so the
idea is that we can introduce
circularity and we can recycle the water
insult from those industrial wastewater
streams from the factories and we can
send it to the front end of the
chlor-alkali process
circular salt so how impactful is this
well let's just take one example 50% of
the world's production of propylene
oxide is made through the chlor-alkali
process and that's a total of about five
million tons of propylene oxide on an
annual basis made globally so that's
five million tons of salt mined from the
earth converted through the chlor-alkali
process into propylene oxide and then
during that process five million tons of
salt that ends up in wastewater streams
so five million tonnes is enough salt to
fill three Empire State building's and
that's on an annual basis so you can see
how circular salt can can provide a
barrier to our rivers from this
excessive salty discharge so you might
wonder well gosh these membranes have
been around for a number of years so why
aren't people implementing wastewater
reuse well the bottom line is it costs
money to implement wastewater reuse and
second water in these regions is
undervalued until it's too late
you know and if we don't plan for for
fresh water sustainability there are
some severe consequences you can just
ask one of the world's largest chemical
manufacturers who last year took a 280
million dollar hit due to low River
levels of the Rhine River in Germany you
can ask the residents of Cape Town South
Africa who experienced a year over year
drought drying up their water reserves
and then being asked not to flush their
toilets so you can see we have solutions
here with membranes where where we can
provide pure water we can provide pure
salt using these membranes both of these
to help to protect our rivers for future
generations thank you
[Applause]
[Music]